this is a production of Cornell
University
good thank you all for coming out as
Nina said this I'm going to just talk a
little bit about my dreary experience I
said impatience and vegetables as the
title but it ended up being a whole lot
of other stuff as well so I'll see how
much I can kind of crammed into 40
minutes and still hopefully have more
room for other things to talk about
before I could start though this was one
of the coolest disease phenotypes I've
ever seen this is tomato necrotic
ringspot virus on chili pepper and they
had a whole population of them most of
them look like most diseased plants but
there was one genotype that had this
just really unusual phenotype from the
disease and I thought I have to you know
preserve this for posterity so I just
wanted to share that of i'll be taking
you through my three main internship so
I wrote the trier for the tropical
vegetable Research Center in a kind of
central Thailand chia tai company in
western Thailand and then prince of
songkla university in southern Thailand
just north of the border with Malaysia
I'll get a little bit into some of the
side trips I did as well I had to cut
some of them because there was a lot of
traveling but just to kind of give you
an idea of some of the horticulture that
I kind of experienced while I was over
there so for a lot of people ask me
where Thailand was so I thought this
would be a good kind of primary it's
right there it's not Taiwan that was
another kind of source of confusion and
people also asked me why I was
interested in Thailand one of the big
things is talent has a really strong
agricultural sector they get a lot of
government support for it the royal
family has poured a lot of personal
money into it they've set up kind of
what they call the Royal projects which
are kind of specific projects to kind of
push the boundaries of it agriculture
with in Thailand they like to say that
they're self-sufficient for all crops
except wheat I've never actually seen
any figures to support this but it's
something they like to say and be it's
mostly because of the range of climates
with in tight
and in the northern part you have
temperate areas where you can grow
things like cherries and apples and then
the rest of the country is pretty
tropical you can grow things like rice
and pretty much any others or tropical
food they did try growing wheat and I
met with the wheat breeder a few years
back there and she said they could grow
it during the middle of their winter in
the coolest part of the country but
otherwise it was a complete flop they do
grow barley though that'd be huge
brewing a industry there it's also a
really big hot spot for biodiversity
there's over a hundred native impatient
species most of you all I think know I
did my PhD on impatiens it's a genus of
1,300 so that's a pretty good chunk of
them there's also tons of other families
it's in chip or a CA I mean lots of
towns have two or three native species
that they use in their cooking that adds
kind of different flavors and spices so
it's just kind of fun to be like walking
around and seeing all these species that
might be really really local to that
area a nice climate good food you know
those weren't my primary reasons but
they certainly didn't hurt and also have
some personal history with Thailand my
ex of five years was thai i speak a
little bit of Thai from being with him
and I've been to Thailand twice before
which kind of fed into a lot of the
internships that I have here the first
internship I did was with the tropical
vegetable Research Center but it was at
cos it's at University and at their
campaigns on campus I tried to put
little red dots on the different areas
that I went to in Thailand so this is
about two hours west of Bangkok cusip
tech university is the premier
agriculture university in Thailand their
main campus is in downtown bangkok but
their campaigns on campus is huge they
refer to it as resort-like which i think
is kind of nice they have lots of bodies
of water they you know even the drainage
canals are populated with water lilies
and
you know in Canada so it's a really
beautiful campus just to be wandering
around I happen to be there during the
boy crow town festival which is their
kind of they build these little altars
out of biodegradable material and put
them on the water to worship one of the
water goddesses so it's a really neat
way to kind of see flora culture and
action there this was one of my favorite
ones this is a banana flower that they
peeled back and pinned to itself and
then they use banana stem in the middle
and put a coma farina or globe amaranth
in there and then you light incense and
candles ixora the tropical honeysuckle
this was really nice one I mean I saw
all sorts of different things in the
path big made them out of different
materials but now there's kind of a
eco-friendly twist to it so that the
fish can finish them off and they don't
end up clogging up the waterways but you
can see it gets pretty crowded this was
towards the end of the festival and this
is again you know just one University if
you go into downtown bangkok I mean the
entire canals and rivers are clogged
with these different kind of floating
altars oh and there was a rhinoceros
beetle crossing the road forgot to
mention so the tropical vegetable
research is a national organization I
got a lot of confusion with the APR DC
or the world vegetable Center and
there's even more confusion because
they're right next to each other at the
company's on campus but it's a distinct
organization they have a few different
mandates germplasm is one of the big
ones but they also do breeding and they
do a lot of outreach work it was a real
eye-opener for me I mean I've lived in
the tropics before but it's just a huge
incredible diversity of species that
they work with and work on maintaining
truth in things like this is a relative
of black pepper that was a popular spice
before Chili Peppers were discovered
gack fruit to relatives of bitter melon
that you eat the arils they're high in
front
and then lots of plants just growing
spontaneously around there this is a
wild clay owe me that's used as a
vegetable in parts of Thailand you use
it with a chilli paste then you get like
that for you to use a talker it was
incredible you know I think if this
doesn't morning mention that you see
them outside the cornell store but you
see them growing here is wild plants
really mind-boggling as i mentioned they
do a lot of outreach we led several
tours for classes this was one professor
or one teacher from high school group
climbing one of the trees to bring down
fruits to distribute to the students a
lot of students you know especially as
urbanization kind of goes on they're
getting less and less in touch with
their kind of like rural roots and some
of the indigenous knowledge so they do a
really great job in their indigenous
vegetable garden which I'll touch on in
the next slide trying to educate people
about some of the different herbs and
vegetables that you can use and it was
really popular you know everyone to try
it this the fruit was terrible it's a
blimpie I don't know if any of you know
it which is incredibly sour from oxalic
acid I've never eat it fresh but
everyone was excited just for the new
experience of that I think more than
anything else as I mentioned they have
the indigenous vegetable garden and this
is actually what it originally attracted
me to the TVR see this is a pretty nice
garden on the edge of their research
facility and when I was there before it
had kind of been just in the planning
stages but now they've really set it up
in two distinct areas based on the
different regions of Thailand Thailand
has the northeast area of the north area
central area and south and they have
kind of theme gardens based on those
regions now each with their own kind of
herbs and their own
suppose cotton eyed Joe Pesci was a
master's student when I was there about
seven years ago he's now the head of
germplasm and he has an encyclopedic
knowledge of every single plant within
that garden you know he'd go and we'd
pass it and he could tell me at the Thai
name and the local dialect name and how
you could use it for food and what you
used it for medicine and scientific
studies was just incredible in this case
he is eating the petiole of one of the
taro relatives but just lots of unusual
plants and unusual uses for plants that
I've been familiar with this is a torch
ginger I'd seen in Hawaii it's used as a
cut flower it's really nice because it
lasts a long time but in Thailand it's
also used in soups it has kind of a
gingery tangy flavor to it you can also
eat it fresh the little fibrous I think
to eat fresh but in soup I think it's
pretty tasty and so you could have it as
kind of a dual purpose that way their
main claim to fame as their pepper
germplasm they have over 200 varieties
of chili peppers that they've collected
with it since peppers are new world but
kind of july's varieties they've been in
two different market classes they've
done lots of greeting work and lots of
characterization as well the two big
issues for pepper production are
diseases and then insects and they've
developed one variety it's pretty much
immune to insect critic for the insects
that are a problem in Thailand so now
they're breeding for anthracnose
resistance
other fix problems we did a lot of
sorting of different varieties into
these are insect damage those are
diseased these are the edible ones and
then taking data like that but you can
see a lot of variation they have three
or four different species that have been
distributed within Thailand and they
also have a duplication of the ABR DC's
chili pepper germplasm which is 3,000
accessions they didn't grow all of those
out but they do grow out the Thai ones
and they also do on some seed production
this is a ghost pepper breeding project
that they're working on their the other
one I mean they have a lot of breeding
work but this was one of the things that
I thought it was really interesting
since it's not a crop that we see in the
u.s. that much this is Roselle it's a
hibiscus relative and depending on the
tax on mr. you ask and might even still
be a hibiscus but it's if you have tea
and the t turns red typically it's
because they say it is dried hibiscus
and this is what they're talking about
in Thailand's it's used fresh instead
it's a crop that hasn't received a lot
of reading work but the breeder mouth
did a cross between these two varieties
and got a huge range of variation
White's pink speeches short to all all
sorts of other things I really
interesting at the top also because it
inhibits aspergillus growth and so
people are trying to use kind of capture
that not as good with the red one
because it does everything red but
there's some interest in using one of
the white varieties for things like that
and then they also put it out and dry it
to see what it's like for creating
beverages so it was really neat kind of
seeing that kind of scope of variation
created while I was there they also had
their annual cap hit fair cuz that means
agriculture and tie and this is a huge
event I can't believe they put it on
every year but they do in the course of
one week they had half a million people
come to the campus and kind of visit
around they just they grew up this
entire garden within the course of two
or three months all sorts of hanging
vegetables and different herbs trying to
kind of use things that we think of this
edibles in a more ornamental application
which was really great people were
taking selfies all over the place and
you know wandering around I mean it was
but it was a great experience you know
for people who wouldn't get to grow the
plants otherwise they also sold seeds of
some of the varieties they developed and
they also have a pure seed initiative to
try to kind of make sure the farmers
have access to good quality seed while I
was there I my big thing was brewing tea
they wanted to introduce people to kind
of native thai herbal mixtures are you
prepared one from sunbury allora polla
which is used as an ornamental but it
also is used as a detox not in the kind
of way that we talk about detoxing here
in the US this is actually like a detox
it can be used analogously with
activated charcoal like they say if
you're drinking it don't take medicine
because it'll absorb the medicine but
there's also been some really good
scientific studies on delaying of
diabetes symptoms and improving liver
function which diabetes is a huge
problem in Thailand
so was interesting chatting with folks
about it we also sweetened it with
stevia stevia is not a native thai herb
so there was a lot of interest in that
we sold out of our sepia plants within
the first day or two because of it you
know but it was a really kind of
interesting way of interacting with
people and I also run into several
Cornell alums this is a precedent lutea
de bretagne wang who preceded his
master's in entomology here virtua did
her PhD in horticulture a few years back
and then that's he hath inada who I
never actually met when he was at
Cornell but he was apparently in plant
breeding so he's a professor at casa SI
campaigns and so that was fun having
with him that I mean the fair takes over
the entire campus I could give a whole
presentation just on it but I tried to
encapsulate some of the more interesting
things they have a huge orchid show as
part of it and you know I used to work
at shows in the US but when you can grow
them in the tropics and have the ideal
weather for it i mean the scale just
becomes amazing you know an oncidium
tunnel mokara tunnel you know and then
all of these incredible installations
this was about maybe a fifth of the
whole setup that they had there and then
they also have some more traditional
judging things and they add orchids for
sale that was the other thing price-wise
you can buy what would be a forty-dollar
bandeau orchid for about six bucks there
for collectors nepenthes these are some
of the rarer ones they had a rare
species with six dollars compared to
what you'd pay in the u.s. if like sixty
seventy dollars they had air plants for
thirty cents unless you think it's all
plants they also had animals this was
from their cattle breeding program
they're doing a lot of work trying to
enter grass good genetics into the land
race varieties in Thailand and they also
did some work with chickens which I
don't know a lot about but I know my
advisor is a big chicken fan so I
throw the slide in after I finished
there I've moved on to the chia tai chi
o ties at I owned and run company base
that has kind of expanded to have a
market throughout most of South East and
South Asia they have huge market
penetration within India and Bangladesh
and they work on a really wide range of
crops looking at this I'm realizing i
left off two or three in addition of
these they do research but they also do
production live your seed and they've
also started branching out into
agrochemicals because you know that's
the way that most companies seem to go
I'm not going to go to too much detail
because it's the seed company and you
know proprietary and all of that but I
did take a few photos while I was there
and this was actually the cucumber one
of three cucumber breeders there we went
out and met with some farmers we've been
growing bitter melon varieties and they
were interested in trying some other
varieties from the company so we kind of
gave them seeds talked with them about
their growing conditions it was really
neat you know that they're a household
name within most of Thailand but they're
not really well known outside of
Thailand yet and that's partially a
branding thing so it's been it was a
really interesting experience
they have an alliance with Chuck I but I
don't I don't know the details of it so
you know I got little hints and bits
here and there that you know very
hush-hush they have two main stations
with in Thailand this is Gunja Newbury
where I was for most of the time this is
western Thailand and I think most people
from the US may have heard of bridge
over the river kwai ork why I forgot how
we pronounce it here but that's kind of
what the area is known for it's one of
the hottest driest areas in Thailand and
I was there during the hottest and
driest time but it's it's a nice area
very picturesque lots of you know buttes
and plateaus melt add which is really
pretty if they'll show a tourist area
there's not much there besides tourism
and large expanses of kind of
unpopulated areas but they've managed to
make melons into a kind of major crop
within the area everyone I talked to in
Thailand before I started this
internship said you have to try the
melons in kanchanaburi they're so good
they're really famous and they're really
delicious but they've sort of created
the market for them within the company
this was they have the small sales area
at the research station to kind of you
know build on that and they have things
like you know melon chairs kind of keep
people interested they're really
uncomfortable to the made of concrete
but you know people love taking photos
with them and they if you drive back
from guns on over you to Bangkok you'll
see null installs all along the roads
the entire way back because you know
it's become such a huge part of the
reputation of the area there other
research station is up in chiang mai
chiang mai is much cooler than ganja
newbury or most of thailand it's used to
be a separate Kingdom so it also has a
different culture and slightly different
dialect because if
you can grow a lot of crops up there
that you can't grow in most of Thailand
things like strawberries this is I took
a photo of this because instead of using
black plastic mulch they use leaf debris
and put it down individual it so it's
kind of you know more eco-friendly form
I got to explore the town it's becoming
a huge tourist trap there's been a lot
of movies coming out about it and so
people are kind of blocking mayor by the
dozens but it still has an incredible
flower market where I got to see kind of
what's hot and what's not and then this
was also a these are the native are the
kind of traditional Thai arrangements of
flowers kind of Garland's I replaced on
altars or home from your rear windshield
you're if you're more modern but you
know seeing different kind of
combinations of flowers which was really
fun I did oh and I was also visited by
some folks from for now but skip about
that after i finished with chia tai I
moved down to southern Thailand to hot
guy which is in songkhla so it's like
right above Malaysia it's like yeah
haggai has sort of a bad reputation
unfortunately with most of the world
there was a bombing there a few years
ago and most of the type II polite old I
was going there had never been there and
joked about you know dodging bullets and
things like that I didn't see a single
gun the entire time I was there and you
know which is very different from the US
in some ways and i also thought felt
incredibly say it's a really interesting
area because it's near what used to be a
port town and so it has a lot of
cultural exchange a lot of ethnic
chinese that came in about 100 years ago
so and also it was also a separate
Kingdom and so there's a lot of
interface with a local of Muslim
community that had been part of that
kingdom as well so it's really well
known for a good food culture another
this is the professor I worked with a
Chan parfum peniche apakah Renan he's a
really well known within pharmacognosy
pharmacognosy is the study of making
medicine from plants which I had never
heard of before I came there but it's a
huge field he has grad students from all
over the world and ongoing exchanges
with even more countries he spent a
month in Hawaii while I was there doing
some other research so it was a really
interesting insight into kind of
academic culture they do a lot of
extractions of miracles and ginger and
other things trying to isolate out
different compounds and then testing on
sometimes animal models sometimes cell
models so it was just a really different
experience than what I'm used to I also
ran into a viet cong who did his PhD
here few years back and graduated in
horticulture as well he's now a
professor of doing a lot of the farm
program they're all of the undergrads
who start in agriculture or anything
related to that a required to spend
their first semester working on the
student-run farm and they grow all of
these different vegetables and it's
really fun you know some of them with no
background in it so you see them taking
selfies you know as the cabbage gets
larger and larger and then they take it
you know to market and you're sitting
there trying to tell you on their
cabbage it was a really cool experience
you know getting to see them and he was
kind of intrinsically involved in that
oh the area is really nice as I
mentioned it's sort of near the sea so
there's a lot of like beaches and other
things this is one of the emblematic
thing this is a mermaid kind of like the
one in Copenhagen and then anagha statue
which is one of the mythical creatures
in Thailand i also got to explore some
of the wetland co5 which was really neat
I didn't know Thailand had wetlands but
I went to one of the bio preserves and
they one of the things they had and kind
of payment for us getting a tour was
they asked us to replant a field of palm
trees the old fashioned way using a
stick so all of the students you know
these were pharmacy students with no
background in agriculture at all so
everyone was really excited to sit there
and pound that stick into the ground put
in the palm trees you know which was
really great I went there with a few
this is a postdoc from India Ahmad and
Python grad students from Pakistan and
we also got to try pure palm juice while
we were there where they cut off the tip
of the nail in fluorescence of the palm
collect the SAP and then you drink it
they also had Paul moonshine which they
were Muslims so they didn't try and I
took their share instead it was
incredibly potent but very interesting
you know I could see it catching on here
my research work there was doing Lee for
us and extraction the idea that I
pitched a John Park was looking at
impatience of four different compounds
specifically naphtha Quinn owns
impatience produce chemicals very
similar to the ones in henna so they can
be used for dyeing but they also have
methylated forms and other forms that
aren't found within los own which is the
plant that had nough is extracted from
so we were looking at them and trying to
see what we could kind of do with that
this is the dried leaves of the henna
tree they had one growing their ground
up and then extracting in methanol
evaporating it and then running thin
layer chromatography it was a whole new
experience for me you know
as many of you know I'm much more of a
whole plant person so this was kind of a
fun addition we had a hard time with the
process we ran both hplc and TLC and we
would get conflicting results about you
know we would find henna compounds and
impatience but not in the henna so you
know it was like there's still some
stuff that we're kind of sorting out but
we're talking about maybe doing that
down the road we did find a whole bunch
of compounds that hadn't been described
though so it's some really interesting
work for the future and it could also be
addressed for conservation work for some
of the native impatience species ah I
took quite a few side trips while I was
there as I mentioned these were mostly
around Bangkok one of the things you
know since this is mostly a plant proud
that I wanted to point out is Bangkok
you know despite being pretty much
ippoliti and developed it has really
made an effort to create green spaces
this is outside one of the bouchier
malls in bangkok and it has a really
nice planting of ground covers grasses
there's a green wall nearby and this is
the second floor of a metro stop you
know so they've really like try it made
an effort for that this is the eighth
floor of another mall they've built an
entire outdoor garden with waterfalls
and all sorts of other plants so it was
really kind of neat seeing how they kind
of pushed the green into an urban
landscape I took some obligatory temple
shots I'm not really a religious person
but I mean they're pretty great nor Nate
this was a chinese temple that was in
the middle of one of the thai temples
huge buddhas you know like two or three
stories tall I again you know like I
don't I have other photos of them but it
was a really interesting cultural
experience for that one of the side
trips I took in Chiang Mai awaz to the
Queen Sirikit botanic garden if you have
a chance it's an incredible garden to
visit I met went there mostly because
xfm is the one of the world authorities
some impatience he's done a ton of
research
where he's named countless species and
he runs a lot of their research program
the garden itself is really interesting
they have a canopy walk and like i said
chennai ask a slightly different climate
so you get to see you kind of a whole
different range of plants they had a
rose garden which is not what i expected
to see in Thailand but they have
cultivars that are really well adapted
to the climate there and tons of people
taking selfies with them and then a lot
of other plants as well Vermillion house
and a terrestrial orchid breeding
program which I thought was really neat
you hear a lot of work going on in
Thailand about dendrobium orchids and
Banda orchids but they've done a lot of
work with this is Calanthe II and also
fios so it's something that you know i
think is kind of on the cusp eck was
sort of complaining though that he wants
to push in patients but he said orchid
they're always considered so much sexier
so they get all the funding money you
know so hopefully that will change in
the future I did find a ton of different
impatient species this was everything
that was well a small selection of what
was in flower at the time they had just
an incredible variety of them that X and
other researchers have collected from
different parts of Thailand in the
surrounding area this is a kingdom war
di from the ANA Myanmar it's Kleist
agamous the flowers never fully open
other species you know again all of
these just growing within the area ones
that form calyx is so kind of woody sort
of bulbule stuck type things at the base
of the plant to kind of hang on through
droughts regions there was one that was
neon blue that unfortunately wasn't in
flower but they had photos of and they
said one of the hard things from a
conservation point of view is they don't
have the funding to really keep the
accessions going so it's just kind of
whatever grows kind of keeps growing and
they keep hoping it'll you know persist
we're in talks right now with the new
york botanic garden and striping botanic
garden san francisco to see if we can
get some conservation work going on with
these maybe some breeding work but we'll
see you so it was just an incredible
experience
point of view too I took a side trip to
Taiwan because my visa ran out and met
up with a just nary a breeder who I knew
from the u.s. wake wang lin he's now
working at they're out in Nebraska but
he kind of showed me around I'd never
been to Taiwan until I was amazed again
you know a lot of use of green space
there this is a park that's I think two
years old but they've completely turned
over what was a slum before they we took
a bike trip through the middle of town
they've really worked on kind of
building up green spaces we hiked to the
top of a mountain unfortunately was near
the beginning of chinese new year so
everyone was hiking to the top of the
mountain but it was a really great
experience you know and really again you
know it's an interesting intersection
between Chinese culture and tropical
climate so orchids being utilized in
different ways really like me I also
went to Malaysia because it was a really
quick hop from southern Thailand to
Malaysia and met up with to Cornell
alums from food science a DAC Kien and
ting zhu tan they're both professors in
food science now I'll get into some of
the Botanical Gardens there although
again you know I could go on and on
about that but kangju works at a
university next to the ocean so I went
in visit with him there explored the
plant life in some of the beaches a
little bit but also went around downtown
kuala lumpur and again i was surprised
at some of the use of plants there these
are irises and ornamental grasses that
they keep alive throughout the year
inside they weren't in bloom at this
time but I'm told they're really
spectacular when they do bloom and
throughout the entire inside of the mall
the as I mentioned there's two main
botanic gardens I visited one inside
Kuala Lumpur one about an hour south
near one of the
stations for kids are becoming a really
big thing in Malaysia there's been a
push to compete with the Singaporean
market and Aram des which are descended
from this one this is a rack pneus
species have become kind of the go-to
unfortunately while I was there there
was some construction going on but they
kind of had a nice twist on it and Paige
artists to create these murals on the
areas of under construction kind of like
when the commons was under construction
they did the same thing but it was
really nice the things that were in
flower really great and they had key
laconia species I'd never seen before at
a kuch aur kya both of them were more
kind of walking gardens than anything
else one thing I did see and I haven't
seen this as much in us botanic gardens
is they had a whole chart on how to read
a plant label which i think is something
that gets overlooked a lot but was
really nice and it's in English and
Malay so you know I saw a lot of people
stopping and looking at this they had
this at the different entrances or
really kind of enhance the experience
for people who are visiting I'll finish
up your with Singapore for those of you
who don't know Singapore is this teensy
little island right off the end of
Malaysia it's essentially a city state
and it's a one of the economic
powerhouses of Southeast Asia they've
also managed to maintain a pretty green
presence despite being a city-state this
is one of about five or six gardens I
saw in their Airport that they've they
even have a dendrobium orchid that
they've named after the airport it's
really you know devotion they have like
artists stations outside these to like
teach kids how to draw flowers things
like that really neat ways of engaging
with the public and Singapore is also
the only country in the world that has a
hybrid as their national flower which is
kept the ole anthe miss joaquim I think
it used to be called Banda it's one of
the van geishas type
I went to Singapore Botanic Garden and
it is spectacular it's been around since
the 1800s it's really well-established
they have an orchid breeding program
that's I think at least 50 years old if
not older than that they've registered
thousands of orchid Hagrid's they
maintain one of the few chunks of native
rainforest with in Singapore which was
just spectacular and have a lot of em
gardens I was captivated by the
evolution garden because I thought that
would probably lead to all sorts of out
by in the US but it seemed to be a
really well done garden there it's even
this tree is featured on the back of
some Singaporean currency so it's really
integral to the Singaporean culture they
also had a banana and ginger garden I'd
never seen a banana like this before and
was just so excited you know I think we
should have these all over the place and
then a forked fountains as well one
thing that i did find really interesting
but i thought was kind of odd is they
had suggestions about oh this plant
would be great for home landscaping or
oh this plant you know could be used in
this sort of arrangement but singapore
there's almost no garden space because
it's mostly in apartments so i thought
it was a great effort you know i think
that would be something maybe areas with
more of a kind of footprint for the
housing we could really appreciate uh i
also went to a gardens by the bay which
is the other botanic garden there a full
disclosure I just accepted a job with
them so I'll try not to like wax to like
eloquent about it but they are unique in
that they're one of the few gardens that
has a conservatory that's cooled there
Singapore is right on the equator so
they cool both of the conservatories to
grow temperate type plants so that
people in the tropics can see them there
they like to kind of build himself as
kind of creating a sort of Central Park
vibe there in the center of what will be
the
town business district and they're
expanding they owned several properties
as well there's a lot of really neat
architectural features like these are
they call the super trees which are
obviously not trees but they've put in a
lot of epiphytic plants to kind of
create that same sort of feeling and
they have a lot of crosswalks at
different levels to see different things
through which I thought was really need
one of the conservatories is called the
flower dome it has kind of seasonal
changing exhibits the funding is amazing
and so they bring in you know huge
amounts of tulips huge amounts of
dahlias from all over the world I was
there the first time I think was around
the Chinese New Year celebration and
they had just a huge field of dahlias in
the middle of the dome the second time
was tulip mania and they had tulips off
to the place selfie stations garden is
geared more towards people who don't
have the background in horticulture and
they're trying to kind of bring people
in so you know it wasn't like some of
the other botanic gardens I've been to
where it's very kind of much more about
like oh this is a botanical jam it was
there was a lot more spectacle but kind
of trying to attract people with that
and then kind of teach them whether they
liked it or not kind of thing yeah they
also had brought in five full-size palm
trees from Chile several thousand year
old olive trees from Spain okay it's a
really credible undertaking and the
gardens only three years old last year I
think I said they had over eight million
visitors so it's really taken off the
other dome is a cloud forest that
they've built inside it has several
waterfalls and then also walks going
around different parts of it it's I
think seven stories tall and mostly
focuses on epiphytes and other things
like that but i found an impatient
species and was really excited in the
middle of one of the ponds though so I
kept leaning over trying to get a better
and better photo and finally managed to
get pulled back before I fell in but it
was right in the middle of the
carnivorous plant area which I thought
was really neat too and they again they
try to get people engaged they have a
whole display of stalactites and
stalagmites that they've imported and
geodes to kind
you know add to kind of the feel to it
but people seem to really appreciate it
the outside gardens are really nice as
well there's a lot of water features
because it is by the bay and it's it
used to be brackish water it's now
mostly fresh water and then it's also
become a very popular spot for sportsmen
so as I mentioned they're kind of
creating a central park five so a lot of
joggers go through and if you get there
at around six in the evening when the
workday ends you'll get like almost a
traffic jam of joggers kind of jogging
through here it's gotten to the point
they now actually have a host a marathon
to kind of channel some of that I think
they have different restaurants around
the area as well you can accommodate it
but I think it's kind of a sneaky way to
introduce people to plants to you know
you get to see things their flowering at
the same time uh with that I'll just
finish up a few people had asked me
about tips for applying for the trier
and so I thought I'd just mention a few
things if any of you are interested in
applying one of the things I think that
really is important is having a focus
theme or plan for your proposal you know
I've heard several times I think the
committee told me as well you know
making sure that you can really
definitively say something rather than I
want to go to Thailand you know just
kind of like saying okay this is what
you're focusing on I personally I think
outlining your internship with the folks
at the place would be really good I
speak from kind of my own personal
experience here where I didn't outline
some of the things and it was like oh
you want to do that well the person who
would do that is out of town so kind of
making sure that everything's kind of
planned out before you go figure out
your visa is early on so you're not
leaving the country every month trying
to renew it like I did for the last four
months but if not use as an excuse to
travel write your reports well in
advance that
I struggle with and to take lots of side
trips of I kind of felt conflicted
sometimes about like oh I mean here I
should be doing more of this and more of
that but I also would say you know it's
important to take some time off to you
know there were times where you just
kind of sit in their coffee shop and
appreciate the fact that you are where
you are you know you don't have to be
filling each moment with that I'll thank
the drear committee thank you so so much
for this incredible opportunity I was
really life-changing and not just
because it's a job offer and it's just
totally been eye-opening in so many
wonderful ways I'd like to thank my PhD
committee since they helped me kind of
get push through the last part of it and
really held on to kind of hold me to it
to get everything in and then I'd like
to thank the people at the different
organizations who were kind of in charge
while i was there Chum Namsan Coons was
the head of PR at the tpr see soup at
mckee anong who's the head of plant
breeding at chia tai and then parfum can
eat I do pecado a man who's the
professor at prince of songkla
university they all were just really
welcoming and were really helpful so
with that I'll take some questions this
was something I saw as a souvenir and I
just thought that was really cool so but
anyway thank you this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell edu